create a graph of the linear equation 5x
plus 2y is equal to 20 so the line is
essentially the set of all coordinate
all X's and Y's that satisfy this
relationship right over here to make
things simpler we're going to do is set
up a table where we're going to put a
bunch of X values in and then figure out
the corresponding Y value based on this
relationship but to make it a little bit
simpler I'm going to solve for y here so
it becomes easier to solve for y for any
given X so we have 5x plus 2y is equal
to 20 if we want to solve for y let's
just get rid of the 5x on the left hand
side so let's subtract 5x from both
sides of this equation the left-hand
side these guys cancel out so we get 2y
is equal to the right hand side you have
20 minus 5x and then you can divide both
sides of this equation by 2 so you
divide both sides by 2 the left hand
side we just have a Y and then the right
hand side we could leave it that way
that actually would be a pretty
straightforward way to leave it but what
we could call this 20 divided by 2 is 10
minus 5x over 2 or minus five-halves
times X and so now using this let's just
come up with a bunch of X values and see
what the corresponding Y values they are
and then just plot them so let me do
this in a new color so let me a slightly
different shade of yellow so we have X
values and then let's think about what
the corresponding Y value is going to be
so I'll start well I could start
anywhere I'll start at X is equal to 0
just because that tends to keep things
pretty simple if X is zero then Y is
equal to 10 minus five-halves
times 0 which is equal to 5 halves times
0 is just 0 so it's just 10 minus 0 or
10 so that gives us the coordinate that
point 0 comma 10 when x is 0 Y is 10 so
0 so X is 0 so it's going to be right
here at the middle of the x-axis and you
go up 10 for the y coordinate 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 so it's right over here so
that's the point zero comma 10 let's do
another point
let's say that X is 2 I'm going to pick
multiples of 2 here just so that I get a
nice clean answer here so when X is 2
then Y is equal to 10 minus five-halves
times 2 and the 2 in the denominator
cancels out with this 2 in the
denominator in the numerator so it
simplifies to 10 minus 5 or just 5 so
that tells us the point x equals 2 y is
equal to 5 is on the line so 2 X is
equal to 1/2 right over here and then Y
is equal to 5 we go up 5 1 2 3 4 5 just
like that so that's the point 2 5 and
when you're drawing a line you actually
just need two points we could if we have
a ruler or any kind of straightedge we
can just connect these two points and if
we do it neatly every every point on
that line should satisfy this
relationship right here just so we get
practice I'll do more points so let me
do let's say when X is equal to 4 then Y
is equal to 10 minus five-halves times 4
this is equal to 5 halves times 4 this
is equal to 10 right because the two
divide the denominator by 2 you get 1
divide the numerator by 2 you get 2 or 4
over 2 is the same thing as 2 so it
becomes 2 times 5 is 10 10 minus 10 is 0
so the point 4 comma 0 is on our line so
X is 1 2 3 4 and then Y is 0 so we don't
move up at all so we have 4 4 comma 0
and I could keep going I could try other
points you could do them if you like but
this is plenty just two of these would
have been enough to draw the line so let
me just let me just draw it so I'll do
it in white so the line will look
something like this the line will look
something the line will look something
like something like that and I could
keep going in both directions so there
you have it that is the graph of our
linear equation let me make the my line
a little bit bolder just in case you
found that first line hard to read so
let me make it a little bit bolder I
think you get the general idea
you